I'm really really busy doing some stuff and...
Yeah, yeah, don't give him too much attention
That's why I can't be there...
Happy birthday, have a great night
Who let them out? No one knows.
No one ever solved that mystery
Alright, okay
We gettin' close
You all know the drill
Intercept the convoy
Watch out for Cable
Hit it
There's this kid. He's in trouble
Move or die
Pump the hate brakes, Thanos
I ain't letting Cable get to him
But I can't do this alone
We need back up
We're gonna form a super duper fucking group.
It's time to get back on LinkedIn
Meet Bedlam
My name is Shatterstar
Domino. I'm lucky
Luck isn't a superpower.
It's certainly not very cinematic
Yes, it is
Let's meet in the middle and say no it isn't
Fuck it, it's showtime
You're no fucking hero
You're just a clown
Dressed up as a sex toy
So dark! You sure you're not from the DC Universe?
Bring it on, one-eyed Willy
Whoo! Yeah! Your bullets, they're really fast
And last but not least...
Peter
Any powers you wanna tell us about?
I don't have one. Um, I just saw the ad
You're in